there's tons of studies out there around
how much the bitcoin network actually is
consuming uh what is your like what
study or what data point do you use if
you had to measure it on like the global
energy consumption is there a number
that you point to i usually look at the
number that is 0.1 of total global
energy consumption what do you use when
thinking about this yeah we use
cambridge university's numbers which
lays it out but they come in about a
half a percent and that's really
important that's
end user electricity right i think
correctly i'm wrong i'd be interested to
know your denominator and your numerator
um but i think if you're using base
primary energy coming into a country
that would be like the theoretical
energy com
content of a barrel of oil you know you
got to convert that to electricity or
other things you lose most of it in the
conversion so the relevant number should
be electricity that's usable by end
users right and that's also really
important in climate because the world
has to electrify everything right that's
the that's the challenge here it's
incredibly hard it's going to take a
long time and then so that total global
number is going to be 23 peta uh watt
hours right and bitcoin's coming in at
130 terawatt hours that's about half a
percent
so when you think about this one of the
things that to me is fascinating is even
if transaction fees exploded which is
part of the miner's revenue even if
bitcoin's price exploded and so there
was a bigger economic incentive for
people to mine and today you know
there's 40 million dollars or so miners
are being paid per day uh globally if
that exploded upwards and it went to 200
billion dollars right in a given year
that they were actually pulling in from
a uh
from an economic incentive standpoint
the thing that i always jumped to is
like even with that 200 billion dollars
of economic incentive they couldn't buy
more than one percent of the global
energy right just 200 billion dollars as
their revenue if they went and spend
every single dollar buying energy and so
they made no profit it still would only
get you about 0.9
based on the numbers i've looked at so
how do you think about
even with the revenue that they get it
ends up just being a limiting factor on
how much energy they could purchase in
the future
well i don't get where you're coming
from with that i mean they could set up
shop in saudi arabia and basically you
know be the number one customer right if
the saudis want to do that look the the
big problem is the big number right now
130 trillion watt hours but that's up 10
action five years that's the alarming
part here right and why is that because
the price has gone up right you had two
havings in those five years by the way
you go out another five years of that
you're going to be using more
electricity and then in japan right
you're going to be at one uh pedowatt
hour um
that's four percent of the world's elect
use end user electricity right that's a
problem that's a big problem you look at
people fighting climate you can't ignore
that right and again i would just say
like if that happens like that's in five
years
where's climate in five years it's going
to be worse right because we're way
behind the curve here
there's just no way that companies and
liquidity providers aren't going to be
just they're going to be picking it
they're going to be scared to death
because they feel like what happened in
russia here where all these you know
it's not just sanctions but the
companies move out
and that's going to be devastating to
the growth of bitcoin that's what you
hit that wall right so that's why change
the code and change the proof of work
don't go to proof of stake change the
proof of work flip the equation there
right you got that mining infrastructure
is
that is nobody else has that imagine
those things sucking carbon out of the
if they were incented to set carbon out
or maybe produce renewable energies now
like i get it right right now you got a
beautiful solution and you don't don't
have to prove the work the result proves
the work right it's math
um you got to figure out a different way
if you're going to be counting co2
sucked out or renewable energy pumped in
for free to the grid imagine you had
that right but again bottom line if
people can make money
like they have been on bitcoin and it's
helping the climate that's unstoppable
that's carbon coin
that's the mythical carbon coin right
there so so to get to four percent
energy consumption globally it would
cost about 800 billion dollars
and the miners just don't have that
money i think that's where the bitcoin
community says well hold on a second
like even if fee spiked and bitcoin went
up 100x they literally wouldn't have
enough money to buy four percent of
global energy and so i think that when i
look at this the other key piece to this
is that the legacy finance system i
think you and i both uh would agree on
this is pretty non-controversial the
more users the more transactions the
more transaction volume the more energy
consumption there's a very linear
relationship right you need more atms
you need more banks you need more data
centers all this type of stuff to
support more users
with bitcoin one of the interesting
things is that the layer one a single
line or single transaction in that block
could represent me sending you one
bitcoin so two-party transaction a
single transaction or it could represent
billions of dollars of economic value
and hundreds of transactions on the
layer 2 like in the lightning network
and so if we scale out the lightning
network at the layer 2 now all of a
sudden there is not a linear
relationship to support more users or
more transactions we don't actually need
to consume more power how do you think
about that as one of the bitcoiners
arguments in terms of why there isn't
this linear relationship between more
users and more energy consumption well
first of all i disagree with your first
calculation there look if the prices
or if the energy uses up 10x that's if
it's four percent yeah you can you can
buy that energy you can afford it's it's
proportional to what you're seeing today
right it's the same equation they're
going to spend up to you know
some profit margin and and that's the
driver um as far as you know kind of
this one transaction look you're still
securing the network there's still this
race to solve that uh that puzzle and
people are going to spend up until the
point where they make a they make a
decent return the thing is like yeah
you're right the the legacy systems use
energy
but they need to be working and many of
them are to reduce it as much as they
can and the only point here is so does
so this is a bitcoin protocol again it's
in there in the interest of the bitcoin
community to do that right and if you
can invent
a better form of proof of work for
example
uh that either gets to neutral or gets
to negative it's the holy grail right um
then do it right why aren't we doing
that that's the thing i don't get
the trillions of dollars in this
industry right the billions of dollars
the miners were why aren't why is there
a crack team here that's supported by
the the bitcoin mining association
that's all they're doing is they're
working on a new breakthrough code base
that would solve this problem well
there's so much money there's so much
talent
we can do this right but there's i think
why are we doing it yeah i think the big
thing is so using your example without
any havings if there was still 900
bitcoin per day coming in and price was
up 10x so the miner revenue was up 10x
it would still only be 146 billion
dollars and so if miners went and spent
every single dollar on energy
they still couldn't buy one percent of
the global energy so 10x increase in
price 146 billion dollars of total minor
revenue globally in a given year they
couldn't spend all 146 billion and buy
one percent and i think that's where one
of the big questions is you know maybe
energy costs come down
some way but i just it's hard for me to
see them getting their hands on 800
billion dollars spending 100 of it and
buying four percent of the energy
production you're using a different
denominator you're using that primary
incoming you know theoretical energy in
a barrel of oil for example the relevant
number in my opinion should be you know
cambridge university number which is the
electricity used that's again 23 peta
watt hours whatever it is
also by the way if it goes up 10x the
price is probably more than that you've
got to having in there but again track
record is 10x in five years continue
that out and look i believe anybody who
said price isn't going to continue to i
don't buy it i think it will like the
track record is there we have to assume
the problem gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and they can't afford
it because the money's there